what about music
they made music uh yeah i should have
said so
ready
to give me the beat boys and free my
soul i want to get lost in your rock and
roll and drift away
[Music]
i was thinking more like a cd or a cd
you're called dude
[Music]
the dreamers
[Music]
andy
attend the tale of sweeney todd
his skin's pale and his eye was odd
yes shave the faces of gentlemen who
never thereafter were heard of again
he tried that you have trod
it's sweeney todd
the demon barber of fleet street
did you write this
no who does steven sondheim who is he
swing your razor wide sweetie hold it to
the side
[Music]
what the hell is happening we are the
cast of sweeney todd the demon barber of
fleet street we open in a couple of
weeks at the loose crew playhouse here
in scranton and today just doing a wee
bit of viral marketing
he served to darken the vengeful god he
served a dark and eventual god
what happens then well that's
[Music]
oh
that was amazing
that was awesome i auditioned for this
when did the cast list go up
like a month ago
really they didn't call me
who am i playing
andy
big turkey
[Applause]
all four parts recorded on my computer
took me forever
nice job thank you much lee
[Music]
you gonna answer it
i called it myself
just let you get a kick out of the new
ring yikes side note
just like to say i'm thrilled to be
working directly beneath you
i feel i have a lot to learn from you
even though you're younger and have less
experience
so
here's to the future
andy and the tudor
in the end the tuna
oh butter tuna magical
[Music]
zombie
zombie
zombie hey
[Music]
mommy love me say that you love
[Music]
i don't care about anything but you
whatever happened to those guys
now folks by special request we're gonna
take it a little old school
there is a former trebler in this room
who it's mr andy bernard
[Applause]
no do not sing that do not he reminded
us today of how much he means to us
and we certainly seem to mean a lot to
him
so without any further ado here's an old
treble classic
dang dang dang do you think
what the hell is broccoli rob doing here
she said you wanted to hear faith that's
broccoli rob's signature song oh but i
need some time off that's my signature
song
i really didn't know that man i just
thought you wanted to hear it
russell i'm dressed like george michael
i thought you were adam lambert
hey everybody it's closing time
you don't got to go home but you can't
stay here
[Music]
closing time
every office needs an end of the day
tradition
something to tell you the day's over
otherwise you go home and the night just
feels like more day it's weird
one last call for out i know it's the
floor
[Music]
oh my boss is saying closing time maybe
that's what you're doing come on pam
close in time
[Music]
let's see andy has been manager for 105
days
which means i've heard closing time
a hundred and five times
still don't know the words
and when that was coming home and home
[Music]
[Music]
won't you take me home take me home
you know what fine i try to start fun
traditions for you guys but if you don't
want to sing no traditions
closing time
every new beginning i never heard that
song before and once i heard it i did
not care for it but that song means it's
time to go home
now
it's my favorite song
every new beginning comes from
good night
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i like that song
you're good
you're good
thank you that was great but it's just
sort of
it's still a little choppy like but
don't worry it's hard it took me a while
too it's like
[Music]
wow what oh my god you heard that i'm so
embarrassed
i'm so like rusty good you're really
coming along it's really technically
proficient but you know there's really
no heart or soul in it really
[Music]
hey you want to sing with me
west virginia
blue red mountains
river in german just leaving east
outdoors
[Music]
young
west virginia
take me home
country room
pick it in there
[Music]
you have to stop
you